is final weekend and the current run is
this weekend and then you can catch him
again may 27 just in time for memorial
day weekend
i think we're running this bathroom she
was helping him put his clothes on oh my
goodness
all right introducing ship and dale's
not newest member this is actually
chippendale's former member this is a
couple years ago right nate yeah well
i tried to get a residency and they they
said no you can go to an apartment you
can go to a hubble but you can't have a
residency
you've been working out though i know he
was not eating those tiny tacos then let
me tell you
thank you to andres back in the uh
control room for his photoshop
is there oil on your chest
i thought i smelled a little coconut
not right now
maybe later
maybe later this is good
hold me back heather what is going on
here and you got the tattoo too yeah
thank you so i thought that you guys
were talking about
lady gaga giving you a lap dance are you
giving her no no no no no
yeah he wants to give her a lap dance
yeah i mean but if lady gaga wanted to
give us the left dance we probably
wouldn't say no it's lady gaga i'd go
for a concert really just okay
wow we are way off the rails aren't we